The answer is none of the above actually work. Well, if we did the close here,
that would work as long as there's no exceptions. The problem is, what happens
if we had an exception on the writing. Well, that would jump to the except
handler. We'd never close the file. So, maybe it's better to do the close here.
Well, then that would close the file in the case where there's an exception, but
if we didn't also close it here, it wouldn't close it when there's no exception.
We could try to do it here. And for this code, this may be the best answer other
than none of the above. Where we go into trouble if we close the code here, if
say inside the exception block we exited. Which would be a fairly common thing
to do, if we don't want the program to proceed if it can't write to file. It
would also be a problem if we weren't able to open the file, which is probably
the most common reason for the exception. Well, then there's no file to close.
So, we've got a problem, none of these work.